on fait un match de ping pong vous avez
des goûts vous battiez ouais si je perds
chez michael jackson d'accord et si je
perds tu fais mais quel est le prince
fils tu fais le dinosaure le
dinosauroïde un don ce que vous voulez
allez c'est parti
attention enfin bon pour deux points
gagnera cela conforte de points gagnants
juste les chéris vous êtes prêts si vous
gagnez si vous gagnez je fais je vous
voulez maintenant je peux partir me
mettais à temps partagé un handicap à
quoi je peux partir mon pantalon et jeté
des chaussures banon même même pas
talentueux
alors voilà on fait une balade c'est la
balle un d'entraînement pouvoir tu peux
le niveau réalisant ses bontés laval en
deux points gagnants
la mer c'est parti 1 2 3 top par niveau
voila voila accélère paraît dans la nuit
ce mot là bas
accélère paraît ce passif mathieu selena
est possible passez pas attaquer on
voyait tableau il est né ils sont
entraînés un titre hello 4 ko chaud
cacao notamment quand même un peu
ringarde et ringarde place de masquer un
sûr c'est vite vu juste après ayez un
documentaire sur nous c'est vrai ayant
ma mère sur equidia la quatrième banque
lui avait encore des participants deux
fois gagnant tu me déconcentre autant de
points gagnants on n'a pas vu taylor
swift ou tenu ces grottes mersen
[Applaudissements]